[Music]
in buff gamer news submitted by Joe
million Jamali
tells country ok jamali and both bear
bail bail boos the pain is like w pill
bill thank you feel like they become a
beer yeah throw the shoulder and then
you got it is this about Jim Madden bit
ok this is about Tehran Beckham hmm
professional gamers are now training
like athletes I have a buddy he's like
in the fitness game you think he's like
a formal former football player but he's
actually just really into gaming and
also he likes lifting weights but he
looks [ __ ] yeah NBA teams now have
gaming teams have investments and they
like literally like have signing days
and everything for these these guys yeah
Nike yeah we about to calm geeks got you
I didn't hear that
ok no but yeah even Mikey outfit 16
League of Legends pro team in China so
yeah they're even getting gigantic
sponsorships like that
and so this article here is just
highlighting how a lot of gamers these
days are really taking their career
seriously and there they found that by
being healthier their gaming improves so
not more Cheetos no so that's Derek a
stereotype of like the fat kid like just
eating whole but just junk food well
it's very real yeah yeah this is like it
might be dying down but it's still out
15 people growing up who were doing that
[ __ ] yeah it's real but I guess for like
pro gamers now that's not the case will
they have money for personal trainers in
all kind of [ __ ] true and so they're
saying that now like for example you
know have a lot of gaming teams they end
up getting a house and then everyone
lives in that house so one of the gamers
that they interviewed they said that
they had a their personal chef like come
in and cook every day and after living
there for some time they realized that
they had all gained like 15 20 pounds
and so they had to tell the chef like
hey cut back on the heavy sauce he's
like hand-rolled Doritos
played it all nice form a nacho cheese
individually cheese easily huh 15 6 per
chip homemade but yeah so we're saying
that now the global eSports revenues
have topped 1 billion dollars and 2019
is this right we're getting into gaming
you know who's pissed about this so I
found a bunch of [ __ ] videos in
YouTube of guys who fer I mean for 50
years there's a game called Electric
football you seen it there's a tabletop
and like there's like some kind of I
don't know how it works with magnets or
some [ __ ] but they put little figurines
of little football players on on this
[ __ ] and they turn on the Machine real
quick and all these little football
players they're going - oh what the hell
and then like people fall over sometimes
and [ __ ] but like it's the weirdest [ __ ]
yeah and they take it really serious
right the the guys like design plays and
they like its position all these cats
and move them around and stuff and then
they play it again and they determine if
a quarterback has made a successful pass
or not but yeah dude ease nobody gives
you a look about it okay you know what
this sounds like sounds like [ __ ] war
hammer something war hammers like it's
like it's like you know say you are me
and everything like then you're
basically just sending two armies
together right you're dude yes so it's
so [ __ ] fascinating cuz this is
existed for like 60 years or something
right what though and they probably
watch game console come on though it's
coming up bro we're gonna [ __ ] get
there dude and here we are a billion
dollars later that is amazing dude do
you know about ninja yeah you jump like
five hundred thousand a month right
something like that so yeah yeah
this one he was with Twitter and then
this other counter it was other platform
came out and they paid him a ridiculous
amount
what's it calling a mixer mixer the
JumpShip and he likes it like half the
follow us with him fruits which crazy
five he's only twenty eight Kate um
which is hurting from that if you're a
gamer is your number one I guess
physical focus to not get arthritis cuz
your plane that's so crazy right so
they're saying that like a lot of these
guys they do so this one guy he sleeps
with the wrist brace to prevent carpal
tunnel syndrome
yeah carpal Thomas I mean he's also very
meticulous about stretching his hands he
says thumbs the thumbs are the
moneymakers Kim actually hurts his hand
he goes a doctor he's like what I gotta
work man cuz I can ESPN if a football
player basketball player tears his ACL
with that's it's a huge day in two years
so now they're like I tore my thumbs or
whatever told my thoughts like work
through like their their injuries that
they get do their fans also the [ __ ]
bones I read like the best gamers don't
masturbate because they don't know how
to completely like me never know what a
little straight the cool circles here
you're still on the outside of it well
in a room you're not even on the same
block I made this circle baby yeah we
hired you they fired you the cool guys
the [ __ ] it wasn't an outrageous claim I
will say about the math wait where's the
try not to jerk off yeah I mean you only
use your hands we didn't have to they
probably don't open the doors [ __ ] like
that it's sealed ligands ooh ladies
moneymakers man
they're insured for like a billion
dollars I could see that if they were
like bringing that much money I know
Floyd's hands when you're sure Floyd
Mayweather yeah yeah yeah I've always
confused like how does that work like
which insurance companies like yes you
can buy insurance for almost anything
yeah you really can they said like J
Lo's ass was it a shirt or something -
there's something like that Tom I heard
someone that is like insured for he big
he had to make his here to make his own
like insurance policy because they they
wouldn't let him do his own stunts so he
like got his own specific insurance
policies that he could do his own stunts
that is true because like we are a big
actor they don't want you like riding
motorcycles yeah like production is
[ __ ] if something happens - yeah it's
crazy oh yeah bigger you get the more
restrictions you have on your life
[ __ ] crazy makes sense Tom Cruise
dies and your movie is over yeah yeah
you're feeding how many mouths yeah he's
being so selfish right anyway so back to
this so then one of these gamers you
said that initially he was kind of
worried about hitting the gym because he
didn't want like like what if he got
sore and I get what affect his gaming or
whatever but eventually he realized that
his gaming times or whatever the metrics
is to measure how good he's gaming they
improved after he started working out
and so he works out four times a week
and yeah then he's really mindful of the
food that he intake so he makes sure
that it's like lots of protein lots of
fats and all that and then saying that
with better with taking better care of
his body he's able to sleep better he
has a better mood like a better mood and
more confidence and so it all is
reflected in his gaming I think him
saying that he didn't want to work out
because he was afraid it might affect
his gaming is the fattest [ __ ] I've ever
heard in my life how the [ __ ] do you
think curling is gonna make a difference
right here it's [ __ ] curling Bros
squats squatting is gonna [ __ ] up your
thumbs bro
sit down so fantastic he is that's the
problem there's too much of it the
craziest thing is like we're big like it
doesn't matter how much weight you're
losing or how much weight you lost you
still are in constant fear of somebody
saying shut your fat ass
that is that is our kryptonite lady like
yeah I don't think I'm at home I'm just
gonna have a chat are you good at games
not as good like fighting games yet all
right is yeah I'm more like Street
Fighter and Mortal Kombat DC Marvel and
that type of stuff but like I'm not good
at the super game I think your games
right okay not really I'm not good at
shooter game my daughter is really good
at it now she's getting a lot better
she plays myself she's alright like lay
to me dad I'm like no I suck out all
games I used to be really good at him
but then I stopped playing the same
thing like with cereal I used to love
cereal and then when I stopped eating it
for like three years I couldn't do milk
anymore I love cereal if Syria was a
game I'd be the champion go to cereal
cinnamon toast crunch that's a really
good used to be good right but that's
why I always thought these kids because
of the kids and these badass gaming kids
they take they put 30% less sugar and
assist in the series and lame yeah it
doesn't put that sugar into money to
honey nut cheerios or whatever because I
got them for my son and that [ __ ] was so
[ __ ] 30% sugar yeah [ __ ] you back
they just need to light have a dose
cereals like this you have to be over 18
to buy don't [ __ ] up my nostalgia
because these kids a little tobacco in
the back you know you're buying it and
though I can't see you ready absolutely
give me that diabetes yeah you remember
the Trix yogurt yeah it'll make the food
you get the spud the mood
yeah that was rice krispies treats
cereal that was Rice Krispies and then
it was rice krispies teasing and they
got rid of that all the good singers
they'd be like [ __ ] Potter cereals
backed up with popular game out of 91
and it [ __ ] is bad you know what's good
- is french toast crunch oh yeah oh yeah
they got the little leg bread slice
things I [ __ ] that french toast
crunch I like that too
and I [ __ ] with that Cookie Monster
cinnamon toast crunch
father the flakes cocoa puffs [ __ ]
undefeated okay I'm nervous but I hope
you like this cinnamon cinnamon life was
like chicks oh right what yeah really
strawberry the berry one okay you better
clean it up regular corn flakes no sugar
no furrows nothing this one you won't
judge me for okay
wait nuts you like raisin bread yes I
think I was saving it for last Raisin
Bran crunch all day yeah okay now I am
judging you I know me too
tip thank you for saying that cuz I was
never gonna say that yeah you like
regular raisin bran - or that way the
regular raisin bran you low fiber intake
heaven
yeah I shouldn't Cheerios with honey and
slice of the banana that's my [ __ ] my
dream cereal it's all Lucky Charms
with all marshmallows
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]